[Applaudissements]
joyent un 14 juillet défilé du 14
juillet a été ouvert vous voyez pas la
plaque poule de france piloté depuis
cognac un drone rêveur a été mis à
l'honneur et c'est loin d'être un détail
un les forces militaires de neuf pays
frontaliers avec la russie ont défilé
aux côtés des soldats fou c'est un
message très clair on voyait à la
lumière kitchen ce défilé était donc
bien a placé sous le signe de la guerre
est créé tout ce qui est commandos
militaires alem sa natalia elle nous l'a
dit mardi tous les sketchs jacques et
les éléments armés moi j'aime bien ça me
rappelle de mon en france comme must
mais tout de suite je crois que c'est
damien thévenot qui quitteront la suite
redescend un peu
ça tire j'entendais plus rares mais
c'est bon
et comme à chaque 14 juillet de
nombreuses personnalités ont été
distingués de la légion d'honneur une
promotion 2022 qui compte notamment
l'ancien premier ministre jean castex
j'ai
toujours
et
on a ouvert le marché de manière
équilibrée et donc on a fait en sorte un
type d'emploi alors je vais venir parce
que c'est très important les gens qui
étaient pour fermer le marché qui les
efforts rien bouger il était pour que
des jeunes à qui on refuse et tous les
emplois n'en ai pas il ya des milliers
de jeunes venant de quartiers difficiles
à qui on ne donnait même pas de réponse
alors cv qui ont été embauchés par les
vtc grâce à ça ils ont trouvé leur
première activité professionnelle leur
première paye ils peuvent nourrir leur
famille je vais vous dire que je
regrette jamais dans cette vidéo pleine
de grâce d'un peu plus d'une minute on y
voit les deux artistes profité de la
fermeture de l'ouvragé pour travaux de
rénovation
une première depuis 17 ans pour
déambuler dans les coulisses de
l'édifice et surtout à 270 mètres au
dessus du sol
mais ça veut dire qu'il ya une majorité
contre votre politique qui est possible
sur certains qui étaient sur certaines
questions est ce que vous avez peur de
passer à un quinquennat à avoir vos
projets retoqués non
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire ça
quand cela que je crois à l'esprit de
responsabilité des formations politiques
qui sont intangibles bakary a gagné sa
place de chef
[Musique]
une place qu'il n'a jamais convoité
mais se montrera-t-il digne de la
confiance que sa troupe lui accorde
on consomme un peu moins que l'année
dernière déjà déjà un peu parce que tout
le monde le sent le voileux vie et donc
il faut que durant cet été cet automne
on continue de le faire et je pense que
deere c'est une bonne chose parce que
c'est la chasse au gaspillage
énergétique
et vous savez c'est à la fois bon pour
passer ce cap mais les crises doivent
toujours nous apprendre comme le co
ville nous a appris
c'est très bon pour le climat et
l'indépendance justicia la même bataille
est ce que c'est la sobriété une partie
de notre stratégie airbus évalue à 30
9490 le besoin d'avions passagers et
cargos neufs d'ici 2040 et un la flotte
mondiale atteindrait ainsi plus de 2
presque 47 mille appareils contre 22
mille neuf cent en 2020 fait un petit
calcul ça veut dire qu'en 2040 il y
aurait deux fois plus d'avions en
circulation au dessus de nos têtes